patrick corbin back to the mound his
last timeout
five innings six runs allowed on nine
hits
against the phillies trying to get that
era down pete alonso will be the hitter
of five game hitting streak eight out of
twenty chance to give the mets the lead
early here runner at third base lindor
with two outs
and he lines one base head in the mets
again take the early lead
lindor comes in to score alonzo first
pitch going the other way hitting it
hard
an rbi single for alonso his 80th run
bad at end of the year and it's one
nothing new york so here's kevin pillar
two are on with two outs
swinging a miss
there's a good corbin slider trevor
williams makes his third start for the
mets and he has been uh everything the
mets would have wished
since coming over and he has really
filled the void
0.69 era in 13 innings azamat four
outings two starts now al city's escobar
will stand in for the nationals
escobarting 282 in 49 games 12 doubles a
triple two homers another three two
goes that way
backs up conforto and towards the line
now that ball drops and gets by him
weird route out there by the mets right
fielder escobar is going to turn and go
for third a one out triple by al city's
escobar here in the first so here is
juan soto with a runner at third and one
out
ground ball right side that'll tie the
ball game bias thinks about coming home
for some reason didn't have a play at
all escobar comes in and it's 1-1 two in
scoring position for the nats here kibum
hitting 241
half swing did he go he went around
strike three big out for trevor williams
as he caps off the first inning by
striking out key boom and straining two
in scoring position balls now to
jonathan vr with mcneil over at third
and two away
and he does it again
escobar to bell
on one pitch patrick corbin gets vr
escobar tripled and scored in the first
inning
let's hit toward left center field he
might fall in overcomes mcneal and he
slides and makes the catch
that ball was almost perfectly placed
between mcneil and pilar and mcneil
makes a play to save at least one and
maybe two runs and then that's have two
in scoring position i know hernandez
gonna try to put his ball club on top
here hernandez hits a hard-line drive to
right conforta will make the catch
coming in soto tags and now stops as
conforto throws a strike on the fly to
mccann
soto goes back to third
well that's a really good read to hold
up on that because that was deep enough
to score the run that's a hard first out
now carter key boom
that's rolled slowly down to third vr
coming home for the tag play he's out
beautifully done vr gunning to mccann
who slapped the tag on soto for the
second out the mets continue to play
stellar defense now two out runners at
first and second and williams with a
chance to get through the inning here's
alex avila and avila pops it up
who wants it
it's going to be baez
side retired first and third and nobody
out mcneil at the ready in the box
mcneal hits one softly in comes garcia
can't make the tag but called out for
running out of the baseline is pilar
they get the double play but the run
comes home
and it's 2-1 new york and now the lineup
flips over to lane thomas with two on
and nobody out comes another 2-2
thomas to left over is mcneil he won't
get there bob henley is going to wave in
luis garcia and yet again the nationals
have answered a mets run with one of
their own
thomas is a hitting machine
michael conforto is grounded to first
and grounded a second hole for two
went to the fastball gets a ground ball
four to six to three gets patrick corbin
out of the fifth inning now two on one
out as luis garcia is due up
rounded to first alonzo goes to lindor
now back to first williams covering in
time double play side retired
one on the double play and williams
finds his way out of trouble yet again
bronzo leads off the sixth against
patrick corbin
gets this one in the air in a deep left
field back goes hernandez to the warning
track back at the wall it's out of here
pete alonso gives the mets the lead with
a towering home run
his 30th home run of the season
and the mitts go in front 3-2 number 30
was a gorgeous parabola and the mets
have the lead in the sixth inning
congratulations 30 home runs is nice
little
plateau and the mints have a one out
base runner corbin throws over the first
and they've got him picked off pilar was
leaning bell pump fakes chases him
towards second flips off to
the shortstop escobar who will apply the
tag
so patrick corbin gets his third pick
off of the season
for five
for his last five at the plate
right back at corbin goes off his foot
keyboard gloves it
throws across got him luis rojas is
going to ask for a replay on this one
and he was safe so it's an infield hit
for jd davis now the lefty lefty match
up with conforto with two away davis at
second vr at first pitch number 114 of
the afternoon coming from patrick corbin
line drive left center field over to get
it is hernandez he's there
yadiel hernandez on the run and patrick
corbin gets through the top half of the
seventh inning here's luis garcia now
with two outs
garcia
that was a loud noise and it finds the
right center field gab conforto
tried to lunge and make the pick
he instead ends up on the ground garcia
the third and the tying run is now 90
feet away with two outs in the eighth
and lane thomas in the batter's box with
two away lugo ready his pitch swinging a
line drive up the middle baez knocks it
down picks it up throws from his knee
it's in time at first thomas is out a
spectacular play javier baez handling a
line drive smash up the middle knocked
it down picked it up and fired from his
knees to first to get thomas and in the
inning tying run at first nobody out
today soto is over three in a walk
swinging at the first pitch he flies it
down the left field line mcneal hoping
for room into foul ground jumping and he
made the catch
jeff mcneal does it again
into foul ground up near the sidewall
and soto retired for a huge first out
andrew stevenson is a pinch hitter
stevenson has done well as a pinch
hitter 12 for 34 353 escobar the tying
run at second bell the potential winning
run at first
stevenson to right field
escobar is being waived owned by bob
headley can fortos throw
not in time
the nationals have tied it in the night
off of edwin diaz for the second time in
three days andrew stevenson has tied the
ball game in the last inning of
regulation and now the mets going to
challenge to see whether escobar
actually ever touched the play
he's safe
game remains tied josh bell at third 90
feet away
and carter kibum
will dig in against edwin diaz
stevenson takes off ground ball up the
middle the mets can't pick it
the run comes in
josh bell scores and the nets have
walked it off in the bottom of the nine